boris johnson's dad has officially been
metoo'd caroline knox accused you of
touching her inappropriately in 2003.
the writer and former mep has been
accused of slapping the bottoms of not
one but two women caroline knox who's a
former cabinet minister says that the
prime minister's dad smacked her bottom
as hard as he could back in 2003 and
told her that she had a lovely
seat then after that a journalist for
the new statesman magazine came out with
the allegation that the prime minister's
dad tried to fondle her at a political
conference in
2019. johnson senior has taken a leap
out of the prince andrew playbook and
he's denying ever having met his accuser
i have no recollection
of course at the age of 81 he may have
literally forgotten